you came up with the Dodgers right yeah
okay but did you pitch for the Dodgers
are you just in the organization okay no
I came up in 76 I got called up from
double-a in September I got injured in
77 got back at the end of 78 and then 79
I was there 80 81 I was with the club 81
during that strike season they went on
to win the World Series I wasn't on that
postseason roster I rearranged Lasorda's
office as you remember and I ended up
getting traded to Cleveland about a week
later yeah what was the build-up to that
when you go in and you get so upset with
Tommy Lasorda that you just tear
everything apart well I was told that I
was gonna get to start one more game and
the second half of the season it didn't
matter and and Tommy started saying that
the opportunity and because in itself
one thing led to another and I just
started rearranging you know his office
a little bit he didn't care for that but
a career really a life saving moment was
I was gonna throw his role in tear
through the big Frank Sinatra wall
you've been at you saw you know all the
pictures and albums all over the world -
Tommy left Frank and as I started to
throw it Dusty Baker had come into the
office and he grabbed the chair and he's
laughing he told me he said kid he said
you're in enough trouble you don't need
Frank pissed off have you done any
practical jokes lately
hold any pranks on your celebrity
friends you know thinking of one really
after bad I can't but I you know when I
go back to my favorite one of all thank
you I mean we were there for Mark
Grace's first golf tournament and you
know they bring Bill Murray up and
worried you you know he critiques me
really good and then all of a sudden
Gracie grabbed him Mike we started
auction off that trip to Randy Henry's
fantasy camp and Gracie right off the
bat bid $1,000 and he said I - I told my
dad right there gene grace that I was
going to buy him a trip to the fantasy
camp and Murray grabbed the mic and he
said mm was back and forth also and
Gracie said
$10,000 for a trip to Randy honey's
fantasy camp from my dad and Murray
grabs the mic and only like he can and
character he's almost crying because I
told my dad that I would buy in the trip
- Randy Hundley's fantasy camp but my
dad died seven years ago you know we can
go for free any time anyway I thought
that was didn't you use to do stuff to
Mark Harmon all the time the the great
actor do you you guys don't do that
anymore you know mr. Vincey is and all
of that he's just he's kind of hard to
get to you know he's got security around
me but one of my favorite things of all
was when the last week of David
Letterman's show you guys can go back
and look at it Mark Harmon was one of
the guests of course that last week and
it's been a talking about NCS I talked
about all the mean things that I've done
to him but you know he got the you know
he finally got more than even remember
when they put that billboard up on me at
Wrigley right before the all-star game
they not only put my heist my my phone
number on it which that's all we had
yeah for ticket information be also
getting all rich but then they put my
senior high school picture up on that
tag and I I don't know
you know I I don't look good now but I
look back then but the funniest part was
Armand on Letterman he told David he
said yeah here's what happened you know
we bury Axelrod and I our agent we they
cost $17,000 and we called 15 people to
see if they wanted to get even with
Sutcliffe it'll cost you a thousand
dollars and they were in but didn't you
dump like like rocks in his front yard
or something did didn't you do what some
of the dump truck with Mark Harmon he
was he was rearranged and he was redoing
his house which you know he loves to do
a lot of that stuff and he went into
this big storage bin where they had all
the
Chili's and stoves and thank to show
Jennifer Axelrod Barry's wife this stove
is mom is lefty anyway as Jennifer came
out I locked mark into that storage
[Laughter]
chain locks and anyways we're on our way
to the ballpark I was I was playing for
the Cubs that day Berry says well I
wonder where Mark said he didn't answer
his phone and sooo well I know is that
he's like you left him in there
yeah they eventually came to get him out
but yeah that was it you know and and
the favorite thing was his bachelor
party when he brought all of his
celebrity friends to Arizona you know
he's the sexiest man alive on People
magazine and you know when they get out
I've got RINO and Jodi and out there
we're gonna have a game we're gonna play
a game against the Hollywood stars and I
give them t-shirts and hats and
wristbands and his banners are running
out the center-field I was going to hit
him some fly balls to get him loose mark
looked to our agent Axelrod and said
this is awesome he goes what a great guy
rick is and then right as I got him all
the center-field I had the ground crew
[Laughter]
like a BB gun they're all laying on the
ground and they had to crawl off and you
know it was recycled sewer water and of
course I took all their luggage and did
it that so they end up you know wearing
those Cubs t-shirts the rest of the
night so yeah that's why the billboard
went up yeah I can understand that for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]